brought to you by total war warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free hey guys my name is Jess
today is the 24th of May and here's all
the important gave me things at worth
knowing about as of today rocket League
is supporting cross-platform play
between Xbox one and PC developer
psionics have called this a historic
moment in multiplayer gaming as this is
the first Xbox one game to allow cross
play which pc fable legends was planned
to support this feature as well but that
game was canceled psionics also
announced that almost 2 million people
have played rocket League on xbox one
since its febri launched by the time
you're watching this crossplay will be
live and now I'm wishing I'd put this
story later so you'd stick around for
the rest of the show back in march
microsoft said they would natively
support cross-platform play and didn't
rule out the possibility of doing so
with the PlayStation Network psionics
have said they aren't opposed to having
rocket League play across Xbox and
Playstation and said that it's not a
technical matter holding it back but
rather an issue of politics the
divisions next major update is out now
and here's what's new the free 1.2
update called conflict introduces a new
incursion small PvE content list changes
and a bunch of other stuff the new
incursion is called clear sky set in
columbus circle and you need to be level
30 to attempt it but if you're still
playing the division chances are that
won't be a problem you'll now also have
high level targets to take out for
various rewards in the PvE open world
and the dark zone is about to get ninety
percent more frustrating with the
addition of a hijack feature that lets
other players cut your loot free of the
extraction chopper spilling it onto the
ground for the taking you can check out
the full patch left including a bunch of
bug fixes for the game in the story on
site finally Sony reckon they'll have
sold an extra 20 million PlayStation 4's
by April of
yeah sony corporation posted their
forecast for the next financial year
ending much 31 up next year which
projects an eight point three percent
rise in overall sales compared to the
previous vs sony said that ps4 software
sales including sales through the
PlayStation Network in addition to ps4
hardware unit sales will contribute to
the overall increase total ps4 sales are
believed to be about 40 million units at
the moment so the current projection
would put me as for sales at 60 million
next April comparatively the ps3 has
sold more than 80 million units globally
as of November 2013 seven years after
its launch the ps4 has been out for
three years let me know down in that
comment section what you cared about
today and be sure to stop by gamespot
for stories on horizon zero dawn and I'm
particle that is everything I have for
you today but do let me know what
mattered to you and I will see you again
to learn